why would you choose to go back and see
this Tyrant of a father for one last
time it was the only way for me to move
forward like a lot of times if your back
is hurting it may not be your back it
may be something else in your bias
making your back hurt for me I'm like
man why can't I get past this hurdle so
I went back to him I realized that that
was the unsolved mystery was I had
looked at man the eye one more time I
went and I didn't see him anymore as
this Beast found out that his dad used
to beat him really bad it's his dad
would have put him in front of a furnace
open the furnace up with the Flames
coming out and put him right in front of
it have him bare butt naked and he would
whip the [__] out of him and the whole
idea of that is if you move you're gonna
get burned so stay right here and take
your Beating so what happened with him
those demons from his father went to my
father and he tried to transfer him over
to me I had to understand who my father
was I got my answers took those answers
it made myself better from the answers
about him